>> I'LL MAKE IT A VISIT, THE
CHINESE SIDE WILL TAKE FIRM AND
STRONG MEASURES TO SAFEGUARD OUR
SOVEREIGNTY AND TERRITORY.
THE U.S. MUST PRESUME FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANY
CONSEQUENCE.
>> Jason: CHINA WARNS PELOSI
TRIP TO TAIWAN WOULD CROSS A RED
LINE AND KEEPS MAKING THREATS
ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD RESPOND.
TONIGHT WE'RE LEARNING MORE
DETAILS ABOUT WHAT THAT COULD
MEAN.
A REPORTER FOR THE GLOBAL TIMES
WHICH IS CHINESE STATE MEDIA
SUGGESTED ACTUALLY SHOOTING HER
PLANE DOWN WRITING IF U.S.
FIGHTER JETS ESCORT PELOSI'S
PLANE INTO TAIWAN IT IS
INVASION.
THE PEOPLE'S LIBERATION ARMY HAS
THE RIGHT TO FORCIBLY DISPEL
PELOSI' PLANE AND THE U.S.
FIGHTER JETS INCLUDING MAKING
WARNING SHOTS AND TACTICAL
MOVEMENTS OF OBSTRUCTIVE.
IF INEFFECTIVE THEN SHOOT THEM
DOWN.
JOINING US NOW IS MORGAN ORTEGA
THE FORMER SPOKESMAN FOR THE
STATE AND JORDAN CHANG,
INSTITUTE AND SENIOR FELLOW AND
AUTHOR OF AN AMAZING BOOK CALLED
THE GREAT U.S. CHINA TECH WAR, I
HIGHLY RECOMMEND IT.
GORDON, THANKS FOR JOINING US
HERE ON SET, YOU KNOW AN AWFUL
LOT ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE BY THIS
BLUSTERING BY CHINA.
>> THIS VERY WELL MAY NOT BE
BLUSTER.
IT'S INCONCEIVABLE TO US THAT
TAKE PLA, PEOPLE'S LIBERATION
ARMY WOULD SHOOT DOWN PELOSI'S
PLANE BUT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
AT THIS VERY INSTANCE THERE ARE
FOUR CHINESE WARSHIPS IN
JAPANESE TERRITORY WATERS IN THE
EAST CHINA SEA.
CHINESE TROOPS DEEP INTO INDIA
CONTROLLED TERRITORY IN THE
HIMALAYAS.
A FEW WEEKS AGO THE CHINESE
INVOKED A VICE IS IN THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA IN THE PHILIPPINES.
CHINA IS LASHING OUT IT MIGHT BE
TAIWAN BUT IT MIGHT BE SOME
PLACE ELSE.
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
REGIME AT THIS POINT.
>> MORGAN, I WANT TO PLAY THIS
CLIP FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
BECAUSE THE SPOKESPERSON WAS
ASKED TO RESPOND IN WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE THINKS ABOUT THIS.
LISTEN TO THIS AND I WANT TO GET
YOUR RESPONSE.
>> I KNOW YOU'RE ASKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE RHETORIC
THAT WE'RE HEARING FROM CHINA,
BUT AS IT RELATES TO THE
SPEAKER'S, THE SPEAKER'S
TRAVELS, SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
JUST NOT GOING TO SPEAK TO.
RIGHT NOW THAT'S A HYPOTHETICAL.
>> HYPOTHETICAL?
THE WHEEL'S OUT ON THE SECOND IN
LINE TO THE PRESIDENCY OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE WHITE
HOUSE CAN'T STAND BEHIND HER?
>> YEAH.
SO, LISTEN, THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS GOING ON HERE WITH THE
PRESS SECRETARY.
FIRST, I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
DON'T WANT TO CONFIRM THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE'S TRAVEL
UNTIL SHE'S WHEELS DOWN IN
TAIWAN.
TOTALLY GET THAT.
I'VE BEEN THERE A MILLION TIMES.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN ALREADY LET THE CAT OUT OF
THE BAG, SO TO SPEAK, WHENEVER
HE ANSWERED THE QUESTION AND
STARTED TALKING ABOUT IT
PUBLICLY, AND SAID, WELL, YOU
KNOW, THE U S MILITARY DOESN'T
WANT HER TO GO.
IT WAS VERY IRRESPONSIBLE OF
BIDEN TO TALK ABOUT IT PUBLICLY,
TO EVEN ANSWER THE QUESTION, AND
HE SORT OF PUT BEIJING IN THE
CORNER BY DOING THAT.
SECONDLY, THOUGH, EVEN IF YOU
CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE TRIP IN AND
OF ITSELF, YOU HAVE TO ADDRESS
THIS EDITOR OF THE GLOBAL TIMES.
BY THE WAY, HE'S VERY
BOISTEROUS, I THINK HE USED TO
SAY THE WORST THINGS ABOUT ME
WHEN I WAS STATE DEPARTMENT
SPOKESPERSON.
I USED TO LAUGH AT THEM BY THE
WAY AND PRINT THEM OUT AND PUT
THEM ON THE WALL.
MAYBE THEY'LL BE IN MY BOOK ONE
DAY OF THE VERY IF I EVER HAVE
TIME TO WRITE IT LIKE GORDON.
BUT IF YOU EVER ADDRESS THE LIFE
OF THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
THIRD IN LINE TO THE PRESIDENCY,
WHAT DO YOU DO?
YOU HAVE TO STAND UP STRONG AND
EQUIVOCALLY AND SAY ABSOLUTELY
YOU WILL NOT THREATEN THE LIVES
OF TOP U.S. OFFICIALS AND THEY
COULDN'T SAY THAT FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS THE
INCOMPETENCE OF THE PRESS
SECRETARY OR JUST THE WEAK
POSITION OF THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE IN GENERAL.
>> Jason: NOW, GORDON, I WAS
SURPRISED ACTUALLY, YOU GAVE A
MUCH STRONGER ANSWER TO WHAT I
WAS ASKING ABOUT THAN I THOUGHT.
THERE IS A LOT OF DISPUTE ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS BIDEN
PRESIDENT XI CALL.
WHY NOT JUST RELEASE THE
TRANSCRIPT AND PUT IT ALL TO
BED.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOESN'T WANT TO
DO THAT, THOUGH, DO THEY?
>> NO, THEY DON'T BECAUSE IT
WOULD SHOW THAT  XI PINNING TOOK
BIDEN TO THE CLEANERS, WE HAVE
SEEN THAT THE CHINESE HAS GOTTEN
TO THE BETTER OF US EACH AND
EVERY TIME.
THIS PHONE CALL XI THREATENED
THE LIFE OF PRESIDENT BIDENEN.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE HUNG
UP WHEN HE HEARD THAT THREAT ON
HIS LIFE.
THIS IS WRONG AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS ENCOURAGEING THE
CHINESE TO MAKE MORE AND MORE
THREATS AND THAT'S UNLY THE WAY
THIS ADMINISTRATION THINKS IT
SHOULD CONDUCT DMOEN DMOEM'S.
>> Jason: MORGAN I ONLY HAVE 20
SECONDS OR SO BUT THE PROJECTION
OF STRENGTH HAS NEVER BEEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S STRONG SUIT
HAS IT?
>> NO, AND IT'S DANGEROUS FOR
AMERICA AND THE WORLD.
WE ARE REALLY ENTERING A NEW
ERA, A NEW TIME.
CHINA WANTS THE WORLD TO KNOW,
IT'S PUFFING UP ITS FEATHERS
RIGHT?
THEY WANT THE WORLD TO KNOW AND
THINK OF THEM AS A SUPER POWER.
THEY WANT TO BE TREATED WITH THE
RESPECT OF A SUPER POWER AND WE
HAVE TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT THE
THREAT BECAUSE THEY ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT PROJECTING THEIR OWN POWER